[Music]
nestled in between the skincare love
beauty spa and advani's pest control
school here in elmhurst queens is
indo-java a two-aisle mini-mart for all
things indonesian but every tuesday it
turns into the city's smallest
restaurant with truly authentic
indonesian food hi
welcome
you're in luck you got the best table in
the house this is the one
ever see it's also the only table
[Music]
my name is david chayatti i'm the
owner of the indo java
we opened in the java 10 years ago
every tuesday i cook right here for all
the customer
we call wahrungselassa so it's mean
tuesday food stall
this little souprette turned one table
pop-up restaurant isn't complete without
one of the smallest kitchens in the
world our kitchen is very tiny it's a
love kitchen because just enough for two
person
[Laughter]
two people might be a stretch
it's half the size of a broom closet but
it doesn't stop dewy from whipping up
classic indonesian fare like gudeg and
rendang
[Music]
before there is none indonesian store
it's difficult to find the ingredient
from indonesia and we miss the community
if we have a store the indonesian people
will come here and then we still can
talk indonesian language
that's our our dream and then now it's
happened
[Music]
i'm not a professional chef i don't have
any the education chef background so i
just learned from my mom
in the restaurant the chef always hide
in the kitchen i like to talk with the
customer when i serve the food so we can
sharing the story
they always say it next week i have to
come again
[Music]
[Music]
if you want a pastrami sandwich go
if you want a chapter come to [ __ ] delhi
this my friends is the story of the real
new yorker sandwich and the people who
keep the legacy alive i've been eating
here for 20 years any tourists in the
world know the hot doggies but only new
yorkers know where the japanese is
[Music]
on 110th and 1st avenue inside the
bodega best known as haji's we meet
salah my name is salah
[Music]
and i'm the manager of hajji's dealing
grocery for 15 years
we actually invented chapters
your boss let me get two chopped cheese
with everything on it lettuce maybe
ketchup put bacon on it too salt pepper
and vinegar
[Applause]
[Music]
the ingredients is one burger for
example or two burgers you chop it up
good and then you put it with some
scissors that's a cigarette the
seasoning and whatever
you like like lettuce tomatoes onion and
that's sandwich
it's an arabic food but we don't add
cheese over there but when we come here
we do cheese on it
uh on a roll is 375 on a hero that's
cost like five dollars
hajis is located in a part of new york
that's made up of various kinds of
people with a variety of incomes so
keeping chop cheese at a price point
everyone can afford has been a top
priority in fact the chopped cheese has
only gone up a dollar in the last decade
we are here for a long time helping the
community and serving the community [ __ ]
cheese is like everything to the
community because it's affordable and
delicious so everybody like it we sell
about 200 chapters a day gospel of the
chopped cheese has spread beyond harlem
and into bodegas far and wide attracting
loyal new yorkers everywhere it appears
but in the end it all comes back to
haji's and salah
they chop cheese every day but for me
sometimes i don't eat this cheese i make
it like a chap hamburger
it's the same thing but no cheese
so i'm trying to lose weight that's all
[Music]
truffles are just such an elusive
mysterious ingredient these are the
spanish winter black truffles they're
from aragon they just have this alluring
earthiness quality that i've never
tasted before
they kept me totally obsessed with them
for almost 10 years now
my name is ian pakista and i procure
hard to find ingredients from around the
world mainly fresh truffles
i'm a dealer of sorts i deal truffles
out of my car it definitely has this
underground element
[Music]
when i was younger people used to call
me the truffle boy
i started when i was 15 and i'm now 24.
i'm constantly on the hunt for
identifying the most desirable regions
that produce the very best truffles
smell really nice where are these guys
from spain they've never been
successfully cultivated on a commercial
scale and they grow underground and
they're obviously extremely rare and
hard to find that's why they're worth
their weight in gold
as soon as the truffle is found the
clock is constantly ticking because
there's only a seven day shelf life
they're 98 water every single day that a
truffle is unused it's evaporating
i still get excited every time i get a
new travel shipment in
they are sent from
europe to jfk where they're cleared by
fda usda homeland security and customs
i sort them i go through every single
truffle looking for imperfections
and then i basically hop in the car the
box full of truffles all right
and sell to 90
of the
fine dining restaurants in new york
everyone from david chang to sean brock
to 11 madison park la bernadet a variety
of michelin-starred restaurants
[Music]
during travel season we import around
200 000 worth of truffles a week a small
amount of truffles could be
anywhere from five to fifteen thousand
we're dealing with quite a lot of
valuable products
[Music]
i'm doing something that i love it
doesn't even feel like work anymore
my warehouse smells like truffles my car
smells like truffles my apartment it's
like i can't escape trouble just like
they're smothering me which is a great
problem to have i guess
[Music]
on the surface the ganesha temple in
queens seems like just a place of
worship for hindus
hi
but if you take the side entrance down
the hall with all the lights follow the
signs down the stairs follow more signs
down more stairs you'll find
the temple canteen a restaurant serving
food to rival anything you would find in
india
[Music]
this is dr uma maisourikar namaste i am
the president of the hindu temple
society of north america in flushing new
york
the temple came into existence in 1977
and as one of the first of its kind in
north america the temple has become a
cultural hub for hindus throughout the
u.s this is a place like home people who
come to the temple spend their whole day
here they have their worshiping services
in the morning and then very often we
have cultural programs but also they
come here to eat they come to the temple
to eat yes they do come here to eat some
of them come just only to eat not even
to come inside the temple
so in addition to a place of worship a
community center and a wedding venue the
ganesha temple serves cuisine authentic
to south india and is open to the public
and the food is pretty fantastic just
ask the new york times or new york
magazine or anthony bourdain this is
delicious it's not easy to find our
indian food everywhere around the
corners so people come to find authentic
indian food
okay so if you don't know anything about
south indian food here are some of the
must-haves
there's vara i always call that as a
salty donuts idli it is nothing but
puffed rice
somber it is made of lentils very
healthy and most notably dosas there are
at least about eight or nine kinds of
dosas it consists of dao and there is a
filling inside we have about an
authentic indian cooks
in our hinduism we strongly believe
without the offering of food to the
deities our prayer is incomplete and
that's how it really started
but i think when you go to a canteen or
a restaurant you want to enjoy your food
we want to make sure that whether it is
a hindu or a non-hindu should be able to
enjoy the food
who cares really whether it is an indian
restaurant or a non-indian restaurant
you just want to go and eat food
so the next time you're hungry in queens
try the temple
there are countless chinatowns all over
the world and new york boasts one of the
most famous full of cheap produce fish
markets and of course a plethora of
chinese food
but if you hop on the one train take it
to the upper west side you'll find a
chinese restaurant like no other where
half the menu
is something else
this is
78 new york's last cuban chinese
restaurant
how did this unlikely culinary duo come
to be that's a great question enter sam
lee
sorry my wife
my father came over here he started like
his own restaurant with you know cuban
spices and also the chinese food mixed
together
hundreds of thousands of chinese came to
cuba in the 19th and early 20th century
establishing a strong presence on the
island but when castro came to power
most chinese immigrants like sam's
father left many of them coming to the
u.s
and thus cuban chinese food was born
i would say la galida restaurant
is not restaurant
it's a kitchen for upper west ciders we
have oxtail
raw baha which is like a shredded beef
at the same time we serve chinese food
either cooked from you know mainly from
china and they learned the trade when
they got here
and they become very good
so are there any cuban born workers left
i still have a one cuban worker working
for me
my name is antonio wong
i work in the caribbean i started in
1986
i'm born in hamana cuba
while cuban chinese culture is fading
is a snapshot of a strange moment in
time where two vastly different cultures
merged together
the cuban
chinese people getting older and they
don't have any younger people take over
i myself feel like i owe my father who
started this restaurant
so i want to try to make sure that i
carry on the tradition for him
you